so I'd like to just ask you a question
about simulation so I noticed that the
podcast is called simulation and I was
thinking wow Alan must be into rehearsal
practice something why does he call it
simulation so why is your show called
it's called simulation for so many
reasons you know it's so funny that you
know we are here Center for medical
simulation and I think that when you
take simulations and healthcare
simulations and engineering software to
find the right fit for aerospace or for
automotive or whatever industry on an
engineering software side of things or
there's there's simulations used for for
how to calculate the you know the
trajectory of the Rockets that need to
go to the International Space Station
you know there's the the true they're
simulations for for biology the central
dogma of biology and how that actually
works when you when you drop in you know
the like pharmaceuticals into the
biological system how that effect said I
mean it's endless where simulations are
actually applied already in an in real
life and so you know that's you know one
of the reasons of course another one of
the reasons is because this is the
question of if we are in a simulation is
very interesting and it also speaks
greatly to in the next couple of decades
hopefully within 50 years we'll be
running our own simulations and we'll be
able to do things like look back at at
how humans actually evolved from you
know from the Big Bang to the
development of the earth orbiting the
star to the development of life all the
way up to civilization flourishing and
we can actually finally look at all the
artifacts the archaeology of the
Anthropology of the evolution and we can
not have to play the guessing game we
can actually watch how language was
invented how fire was invented how the
wheel was invented and so anyway that's
these are the these are the reasons a
lot who are really a try
to these abilities to kind of predict
and play out and that's why you named it
simulation or yeah yeah that and I would
also say that it's just a lot of the
shows about also asking really
thought-provoking questions to the
leaders at the edge of their fields and
inspiring and engaging other people to
get to the edge and work at the edge and
build the future and so you know the
thought-provoking question you know are
we in a simulation what is consciousness
are we alone in the cosmos the last
question we like to ask our guests is
what is the most beautiful thing in the
world